hey everybody welcome to East LA Nepali
now don't worry you are not missing
anything this is actually Rudy rent
Kamel series and I'm filling in one
episode for today with what I'm gonna
build
which is a bnm dive coaster now a little
bit about the series before we get into
this basically easily nepali is sort of
a soft reset almost for Rudy's channel
he had a lot of projects running but
then the tea makers toolkit came out and
I guess he decided to kind of do things
differently so this series is sort of
taking over his old stuff with much more
of a focus on UGC especially the tea
makers toolkit items of course but also
a lot of integration from the community
itself so taking all of the comments
requests suggestions from all of the
viewers and trying as much as possible
to incorporate them into the park and
make this park as realistic as possible
and he really goes in detail with this
but for me this isn't all to importance
because I'm just gonna be working on a
bnm dive coaster yeah to get started
with this and to introduce this project
a little bit more I decided to hop into
the discord channel from Rudy's is not a
pony chat and kind of ask what all of
the various actors involved in this
project wanted out of this coaster of
course and most of the comments that I
got I sort of collected into an overall
conclusion and based on that I decided
to build a bnm dive coaster basically
there seemed to be mostly a need for a
steel coaster of some kind and and
something that was a very recent
addition to the park very much a big
thrilling major coaster and also a
coaster that was built in a certain
section of the park obviously Rudy has
his his plans for the rest of the place
and I didn't want to do too much on that
so this section of the park was more or
less cut out for me too
go haywire I suppose and built when I
was feeling like building but at the
same time he also wanted me and a lot of
people were asking to use the terrain to
my advantage as Muslim as much as
possible
so what really seemed like the best
option here is to try and use the canyon
as a way to really immerse this this
coaster in the natural environment of
the island and another suggestion which
was very decisive for me was to build a
bnm dive coaster and use some kind of
quote-unquote great hole in the ground
as the central aspects for the people
who are of ride and viewing this coaster
so what I decided to build is in the end
what you're sort of seeing taking its
shape over here a dive goes through with
a very small lift hill at the start and
a station very much elevated above most
of the track and this is really also the
only part where it actually interacts
with the parts and where you can see
this coaster from the rest of the park
it just has that small lift Hill and a
vertical drop but after that it goes
into a tunnel that comes out in almost
completely different worlds down here in
the canyon and actually does some pretty
typical dive coaster stuff I would say
going into a very standard first
inversion and climbing up again for a
second drop as a lot of these large dive
coasters do that said I really wanted to
make this different than most dive
coaster so where I think this is really
unique is definitely in its setting and
the way in which is in which it uses the
terrain so I'm really trying as much as
possible to stick to the natural terrain
which we have over here and also for
instance is very low to the ground curve
into this this this turn around elements
that's very close to the canyon walls
and welcome back to some other elements
throughout the rest of the layouts now I
did have some real-life inspiration for
this coaster most notably a B&M dive
coaster in Happy Valley Chengdu which is
apparently called western regions heaven
it's it's one of the most ridiculous
coaster names and a really amazing
example of how weird names in China are
sometimes but yeah it's called western
regions heaven on roller coaster
database but then on my upper
marseillais youtube channel he said that
the sign in front of the coaster says
flying up sorrows in western regions so
I'm not actually entirely sure what this
thing is called in any case it has a
really weird name and it has a bit of a
strange layout too but it has a really
cool color scheme and it was a pretty
good inspiration for the drop on this
coaster so basically it has a very
similar turquoise and dark bright
saturated purple color scheme that I
decided to tone down a little bit for
this coaster so it's a little bit less
saturated and the purple drifts more
toward a dark blue rather than a very
bright almost dark pink that it is in
the original ride but it's a very
similar color scheme and I think it
really fits the the tropical look of the
coaster and also this is a rare B&M dive
coaster which has a straight section
before the drop normally beam and dive
coasters have their lift hill and then
they go into a 90 degree turn and only
then do they go through the vertical
drop but in this case I wanted to save
as much space as I could because Rudy
still wanted to build a restaurant next
to this which would be close to the sea
so I didn't have too much space to put
my station and transfer track and all of
that and also I really couldn't figure
out a good layout or a good looking
first drop if it just kind of dropped
into the ground like that so I decided
it's very much like western regions have
it I'm just gonna call it that to have a
straight section before the drop and
really this is sort of unheard of for a
BNN dive coaster and it used to be
completely unheard of until Baron 1898
in the efteling was built and I
suspected that Baron 1898 is an
exception because the efteling wanted to
be an M to put a a straight section in
there so they could theme the drop to a
my
shaft tower which is beautiful and it
works out very well for the efteling but
then the the Happy Valley coaster
actually doesn't really have teaming
definitely not attached to the coaster
itself so it's kind of strange to see
that same sort of drop shape without any
decorative supports as Baron 1898 has
and it kind of looks a little bit
I don't know naked almost it looks very
strange to see your bnm dive coaster
without that signature turn and without
the signature support structure that
Baron 1898 has but yeah it fits for this
coaster and I'll take all the supports
at some point later in the ride for now
I'm just finishing up the layout with a
splashdown elements and then a barrel
roll at the end now this is kind of a
slight departure from what my layout was
like earlier just because the earlier
layout sort of drifted toward the end of
the layout kind of meandering through
these curves and hills and didn't really
add anything thrilling
at the second part of the layouts and
while this is pretty realistic I'd say
for a benign dive coaster to be almost a
lot of them have second parts of the
layout that are just really boring
compared to the first part that's not
really something I wanted to do so I
decided in the end to change up the
layout a little bit and add some
interesting elements at the end you know
still very much in the dive coaster
spirits so it's splashdown as you see on
a lot of these things and which this
coaster type is really meant for it has
the splashdown
things at the end of the the last car so
that's sort of what frontier I suppose
wants you to do with this coaster as
well and finally a very slow barrel roll
with a lot of hang time just because it
looks pretty cool I think it took a lot
of work to smooth that thing though and
a lot of that is also off-camera because
for some of it I didn't want to record
it and for other parts I just forgot to
record it so there's also a section
where I'm working on the lift Hill
supports where I actually forgot to hit
record so yeah I am missing that part I
also don't know what's up with the
catwalks over here but
fixed itself when I built them backwards
so I guess it's not too much of a
problem but it was really weird to sort
of see the catwalks go hit why her for a
second but yeah this is basically the
layout and at this point I'm just kind
of testing it seeing what all the speeds
are like etc I got to be completely
honest I always have to remove a lot of
footage of myself just looking at the
coaster because come on it's just it's
just really fun to look at your coaster
when it's done and just kind of watch it
run in blended coaster sometimes I just
still kind of think you know how blessed
I am maybe I'm putting it too
dramatically but no having a game like
this has always been a sort of pipe
dream for me especially from when I was
younger and and try to do the same kind
of thing in rollercoaster 3 and to be
able to do this thing so realistically
in planet coaster it's still amazing in
any case that's the the self-made tunnel
over there I didn't really want to take
a tunnel from the game itself because I
wanted the the tunnel to sort of have an
oval shape to follow the shape of the
cars and to have the bottom of the track
stay very close to the ground and if
you're using the auto tunneling you just
get this this massive hole in the ground
which didn't quite look the way I wanted
it to so yeah I decided to dig the
tunnel myself and then over here there's
the path work that's is just sort of a
sketch I suppose rudy is free to do with
this path whenever he wants to this was
just a sort of general idea
whatever you do in Rudy though I would
totally recommend doing something with
the sight line of this this little
structure because being as they are dive
coasters are very often a sort of
winning of a park and they are very much
meant to be looked at and for all kinds
of pedestrians and the people who don't
dare to ride it too gonca from a bench
or whatever so yeah do keep in mind the
the sidelines is about these kinds of
things I think there there are quite
importance
you know you can very much see some
benches around the drop for all of the
people who are waiting for the people on
the ride to see their faces as they're
going down I know for me personally
Baron 1898 is is a great coaster when it
comes to that and honestly I almost like
watching it go
more than I like riding it since when
you ride and you just it's a very short
ride and only they're the first part of
the ride is really intense I think so
watching it and just watching the the
theming and watching it go around is for
me almost more exciting than actually
being on it maybe I'm just a little bit
weird but and general dive coasters are
very much made to sort of be a spectacle
rather than just a ride to ride which in
this case it also makes kind of sense
why the lift shows really the only part
of the right which is in this play since
that's the the key points and then the
rest of the ride is sort of hidden
inside the valley which is also kind of
interesting and over here I'm just
adding some custom supports by the way I
needed to redo that supports because I
didn't actually check whether it was
hitting the cars which it ended up doing
so I had to move this support at some
point but god I still really liked the
supports that were added at last as well
still remember I was really really
surprised but very much positively
surprised they they work out really well
and then over here for the half loop
doing that sort of typical bnm supports
that have loops have obviously a lot of
the supports in game are really good and
they work for most of the cases but in
some cases there are just very signature
style supports for certain inversions or
certain elements which in the end I
think it's best to make them yourself
and oh boy now we get into the little
structure which is really weird I have
to put up first that I built these
little supports just for aesthetic
purposes that's not to say that they
aren't supporting the coaster track in
theory but I both I mostly milk I'm I
mostly built them there we go because I
I wanted the little structure to look a
bit different from just the regular old
supports I I guess I'll get a picture
over here of gone what is it called
again
although the weird Happy Valley coaster
yeah western regions happen because it
looks like it looks so weird I don't
know if this is just because I am too
much into coasters and I've seen too
many of these things and seeing a bnm
dive coaster look like that just seems
very strange to me or if it really just
looks strange to everyone but it it
almost looks kind of empty like it's
missing something
and I felt the same way when I looked at
the little structure with the in-game
supports as well it didn't quite look as
bulky or as attention-grabbing
as I wanted it to be so yeah I am sort
of over supporting it with these
supports that are a sort of amalgamation
of SNS 4d coaster supports like x2 and
anaconda and age and Aika
but also some Mac water coaster supports
and in the end somebody commented that
they look quite a bit like become a
boomerang supports as well which I guess
I can kind of see that yeah definitely
especially the diagonal parts but yeah
just a an interesting support structure
to make the lift to look a bit more
iconic than just regular old boring
support supports which we have
everywhere anyway and then over here I'm
placing all of these footers just
because the the in-game footers as as
good as they look anyway they all sort
of conformed to the ground instead of
the water and usually you find that when
there is a coaster built over water the
footers are placed just above water
levels so I wanted to do that over here
as well but it's a good thing that these
things are the exact same size as the
regular photos that you get in the game
and fit very much the same style so yeah
here's the transfer track which is very
much hanging off the end of a cliff
right there and I have to be honest in
the sort of narrative of the series I
suppose I am just giving Rudi the
coaster as well as the most important
structural and technical elements so I'm
adding all of the supports and the
transfer track and all of that jazz but
I'm not actually doing any of the
scenery so I might be building a quick
transfer track here but I'm gonna leave
it up to Rudi to solve the issue of how
to hide this thing or how to incorporate
the coaster into the theming of the rest
of the park because I suppose in the
lore of this park if you will where all
of the viewers are the sort of
shareholders like actors involved in the
process I am just a sort of middle man
between bnm and the park doing the
design of the coaster but not really
anything else so I'll leave all of that
after Rudy and his he's not a policy
company and on a bit of attentions
related to that I think I should
probably give a shout out to me up a
Missoni which is the channel that I
talked about earlier I think because he
has a POV of western region on his
YouTube channel it's it's a Chinese
YouTube channel that has a lot of POVs
Chinese coasters and most of them are
unavailable anywhere else I really don't
get how the quality of these videos is
so amazing because it really is but you
can find so many of the Chinese coasters
that you can't find anywhere else on the
internet on there in amazing HD quality
and mostly very well mounted POVs so
yeah great YouTube channel I'm a huge
fan and it's it's been a huge part of my
experience of researching Chinese
coasters and even has a video of a
transport wreck of a dive machine that's
very interesting to check out in any
case as sort of lost elements that I'm
working on in this video here is the
splashdown elements and it kind of took
a little bit of work to make this work
because usually splashdowns in dive
coasters are sort of placed in their own
separate little water pond because the
the level of the water is slightly lower
than the left over the water outside of
that but because this is planet coaster
and I can't really build it like that I
am actually raising the water level
inside this a little bit compared to the
water around it so that should generally
make it work interestingly in the in the
latest
Islam nepali episode really who is also
talking about how it would actually be
amazing if there was some kind of custom
contents of water peace because the
water in planet coaster it's really just
a single sort of animated texture and
it's not actually a solid block so if
you go underneath the texture you don't
really see that you're underwater in a
sense and because of that it would
probably be possible to sort of have a
kind of piece that you can make your own
surfaces of water with
and it would be amazing to have that
because in this case I feel like the
closest thing to making that is to just
use glass and that's what I ended up
using over here as well which doesn't
look too bad actually I quite like it
especially compared to well the
alternative back from the old days which
used to be just art pieces that are
colored blue I guess but especially if
the lights is sort of coming from the
wrong direction and you're you're
looking from this kind of perspective it
turns very white at the end and I I sort
of solved that over here by messing
around a little bit with textures to
make it seem like there is a sort of
thin layer of mist above the splashdown
elements but it's not the best solution
in any case that's it for this video so
if you haven't yet go subscribe to Rudy
rent Kamel and check out the rest of the
easel on Apple II series to see what
happens to the coaster and thank you
guys for watching I'll leave you with
some cinematic shots and a POV of the
coaster
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you